we've got a lot of heat across the
country not only the desert southwest
but parts of the plains and we'll look
at that in just a moment already our
temperatures are up above 100 degrees
104 in aleonte look at nellis cooking at
107
just at the noon hour mountain's edge is
at 105
106 for centennial hills and remember
that humidity is up over 25 percent with
dew points in the 50s there's still
quite a bit of monsoon moisture out
there but it is a little less at the
surface than it was yesterday we'll see
where we get those thunderstorms today
this is a little lesser chance today and
probably the last day for the rest of
the week 89 in cedar city 95 in caliente
105 in mesquite already pumped at 103.
sandy valley at 107. boulder city above
100 loughlin's near 110 and look at
death valley at 1 13 just at the noon
hour so we did have those big
thunderstorms yesterday and they erupted
as we roll back the radar over the
southeast a little bit over the west and
flooding up in mount charleston with
over two inches of rain up at rainbow
canyon officially we picked up record
rainfall for a single day yesterday at
17 hundredths of an inch that gives us a
third of an inch for the year and we are
behind still by two inches of rain that
were there were flood warnings through
the spring mountains yesterday and that
was until 10 o'clock last night that
flooding
still a few neighborhoods out on the
west side did pick up more than a tenth
of an inch and again we saw the best
amounts in the southeast